[Music]
in protest goes wrong news hotdogs
submitted by chocolate
tacos are gonna grab his titty a
journalist sweats idea a journalist was
attacked by a left-wing extremist oh no
what was it the socialist pizza party
yes you read up on this one so we got a
lot of requests for this one I assume
because this guy is Asian maybe so maybe
that's why they were requested maybe I
saw a lot of comments asking for this
one and II know and you know oh this one
yeah yeah yeah so I don't know anything
about I just saw that Joe Rogan did the
interview and I'm like no ng oh no
so there was there was a couple weeks
ago there was a rival protest happening
in Portland Oregon between right-wing
group called the proud boys oh stop it
started as a joke yeah yeah I'm not
kidding what do you want it's not
raining I know in the left-wing group
and Tifa and Tifa thing and I'm like
it's short for anti-fascist yes well
that's good thing to be you would think
I would think and so basically the the
two groups were having a protest like
basically just holding banners and [ __ ]
across the street from each other would
you say that they're kind of extremists
in their side of things yes they both
are yes and I figure if you're willing
to go to a protest you're probably
pretty on a certain level yeah
so and you know he called himself a
photojournalist unless it's like a
woman's breast cancer awareness March I
think those people are that extreme yeah
yeah no those are usually in support
good point supportive entities so and II
know he comes off a photojournalist he
he calls himself that like the other
people thought well a lot of a lot of a
lot of sight a lot of places call him a
conservative Journal there's a lot of it
he doesn't he says that he's not a
conservative he has no political staff I
think there's a lot of quick opinion
pieces that kind
piggybacked off of each other that I
feel like didn't represent who he is
he's just a photojournalist but he paint
they paint him as this conservative
publications so he's done stuff for Wall
Street Journal
I forgot the names but that's one of
them but he not only has he written four
but he's submitted pictures and done
other stuff yeah yeah so this guy he he
basically he's known by antifa
because he has he has called out and
Auntie foe violence he's reported on
Antigua violence and so antifa knows of
this guy right and so when he showed up
to the protest he says that he started
getting followed by an Tifa and that he
started getting pestered by them and
they threw milkshakes at him and they
threw rocks at him and then he had a
brain hemorrhage from it Wow yeah I
think like there's a video and yeah yeah
there's like a bunch of guys they kicked
them and and they're wearing masks and
then like they they were stomping on him
and got jumped yeah oh yeah he's got
that Kanye jaw yeah more of him giving
you got how do you get a brain I measure
I'm getting hit with a milk I know like
about 12 people there so and then they
were throwing milkshakes at him and then
they started chucking rocks in and
started beating him and then police also
said that some people were putting
quikrete into the milkshake but they
they don't know that that's part of what
hit him they just know that that was
happening there too so they prepared for
yeah what the [ __ ] bit like they just
come with [ __ ] to start rioting both
both sides were I think I think an Tifa
was brandishing weapons cloaking them
and I think also the pad boys were
brandishing weapons like covertly like
in jackets and [ __ ] and he's okay though
he he says that he stills he possibly
will have memory loss for the next six
months and yeah she's having issues with
some cognitive functions and he says
that it's not a parent but he's doing
scythe I've watched a few interviews
with him and he does have a slow speech
pattern
and I don't know if he always spoke that
way but it kind of feels like it takes
him a while to answer certain things did
anybody get arrested or anything no
that's the thing one of his biggest
issues is with the city so there's a
huge unraveling of what happened and all
for one
he's been specifically targeted by
antiva because he wrote a piece about
them because he wanted to investigate as
a journalist to see what is going down
with an extremist far-left group that
never gets covered in the mail because a
lot of things get covered on the on the
on the floor right because they're all
so violent and dangerous and whatever
yeah and maybe they don't I don't know
and maybe people don't understand that
and Tifa is also a very extreme group
and correct me if I'm wrong but isn't it
like journalists aren't your they're
supposed to be like Switzerland in that
you're not supposed to harm them in
things like protests and riot and war
and that's why it's always such a big
deal when a journalist like overseas
gets captured yes right but the anti-fog
group is an extremist group and they see
his work as an attack to their group so
he's been called a white supremacist and
then it's weird cuz but he says that in
their vocabulary and in their world it
makes sense because he's helping the
white supremacist agenda oh so he's like
he's a sympathizer he's yeah and and so
in what's kind of weird cuz like I've
seen a picture of an Tifa they're all
like there's a lot of white guys in
there and I'm like it's almost all white
guys so you you have all these white
guys calling these minorities racists
and then you're like jumping them and
it's like that's so weird right I don't
get it just as bad as a right-wing
violence and that's what Annie knows
trying to say yeah so so he he basically
goes into like protests takes pictures
and all that stuff and I guess during
this which happened on June 29 or
something like that he yeah he basically
got jobbed because they were like that's
that [ __ ] that did this
yeah and I guess aunt Eva is known to be
more violent and aggressive with their
actions so they're not like a they're
not like a group like Greenpeace and
like sits in silent protest no they're
like running up and pepper spraying
people and like throwing things yeah
it's almost like they're trying to fight
fight violence with violence because
they probably feel like victimized like
there's no other way how are we gonna
get through to these people but now
they're becoming the attacker yeah yeah
and as I was doing my whole research on
it it seemed like it started off like
that like kind of like hey there's all
these like white supremacist guys white
Savior here oh yeah we gotta do
something about it you know and then
like they wear masks cuz they don't want
to get Doc's by the other guys and then
they're like let's get in and help these
people out but I don't know it's just I
think the violence is just bad on both
sides yeah and this is one of those that
actually broke through into the
mainstream because there's been attacks
before from nti like there was this one
called the bike lock attacker who
basically took a bike lock put it in
like a sock and like hit a guy in the
head fractured part of his skull that's
crazy and that guy got doxxed because
they were trying to find out who the
[ __ ] did this so they could charge him
so that's what a lot of a lot of the
left-wing sites are saying that a me
know docks is an Tifa but a Nino says I
help identify people who committed acts
of violence on both sides oh that's why
they wanted to attack him so badly
that's what he says yeah well the daxing
incident actually he explains it and
he's never actually doxed anyone that
hasn't been identified but identified by
media before so Andy know is talk to
these people that's what they're
claiming is he's Daxing people or is he
leading to the daxing like he's like the
gateway into letting people Doc's know
he's identifying people who that the
media already like so
going exactly right so he's dropping
names but these people have been
published elsewhere right just help me
get the word out that this happened and
he's like I recognize for example one of
them is I recognize this woman before
she was caught for creating some
destroying sound equipment during a
speech or something some I guess Google
exec was coming to talk and then she
came and she destroyed it she was on the
news for that and he identified her at
the protest so she was already on the
news prior to and he's like oh I
recognized this lady and then he wrote
her name and then 90 was like yeah he's
dachshund and a lot of NT and Tifa
sympathizers feel like and Ino was
agitating them just by being there and
reporting on it like he's a agitator
kind of like oh the proud boys are an
agitator for yes so he's saying that I'm
trying to document because there's a lot
in the media about right-wing stuff
right exactly laughter seeing him is
right right right it's kind of like he's
not a it's the classic tribalism [ __ ]
like I got to put you in a group because
I don't know what you are so some like
the problem here is this ain't even
nonsense
are they all bad III wouldn't I don't
think so
like I think most extremist groups you
got like a handful of bad crazy ones
that are violent and some people I think
a lot of people actually just join
groups not knowing yeah like I like his
ladder Thursday that's why what I've
heard of the word anty anty fall what is
it anti-fascist I'm like that's dope
like I use it exactly yeah we need
people to like help us out you know yeah
because who doesn't want a more diverse
world and like that's them right like is
it the left job to then like get our
left errs under control
or is it like we should be expending our
energy still trying to fight the right
well it's weird things where who is the
right right so if you're gonna call
someone who's a Republican a Nazi and
then it becomes let's fight Nazis and
I'm an Tifa and I punch Nazis I punch
Republicans so it's just like nobody's
actually communicating anymore just
becomes inflated yeah yeah I think
that's the whole solution here is go
back to
actual debate politics in intellect like
take it out on an on an intellectual
platform but that's what we were
supposed to do is like the free speech
thing is about just getting up on stage
and battling thoughts and that's it's
like it's like a it's like a rap battle
but with like intelligence and politics
very smart I think well it is yeah but
it's not about just like clowning and
roasting right it's like policies and
whatever and it's like cultural issues
or whatever like why can't they do that
and also is that like a time in life
where your political stance is who you
are as a person like unfortunately
that's what I hate me just like have a
dinner with a Republican and like talk
and then at the end of dinner be like
man it's good to see you like dad pop
I'll see you at soccer practice next
week it's like we're cutting you off
from my family like we can't even just
get back to that most basic level of
just human communication with your
conservative you can't have dinner with
a Lib [ __ ] because they're a Lib [ __ ]
yeah well like the way people have to
first preface everything they say with
like oh as a japanese-american straight
male that believes in both left and
right moderate politics and this and
this and my and living in Los Angeles
California that's it it's like damn dude
like why'd you have to [ __ ] do that
[ __ ] I don't get it you're a
presidential debate audience questioner
holy [ __ ]
I swear to God every time as a pregnant
mother of two yeah who lives in
Albuquerque and I have I make this much
of all life story yeah my favorite month
is October cuz I love autumn